the Joe Rogan experience it's hard
because you don't get that many
conversations with people where you
disagree with them and it's not
confrontational usually they're
confrontational or you're
confrontational so it always starts off
on the bad foot I've I've learned how to
do it from doing this podcast and one of
the most surprising things about doing
this podcast is I've learned how to talk
to people better yeah I didn't think
that was a thing I thought I just just
was talking to people but then I
realized somewhere along the way way not
only people listening but sometimes I'm
annoying okay how do i how do I do this
where I'm less annoying and in learning
how to do things that are less annoying
I've become a more compassionate
conversationalist I understand how to
talk to people better and I've gotten
its I apply it to my whole life now I've
gotten better at it and I see people who
are bad at it
it's so frustrating like I have some
really smart friends and you know I talk
to them and they just [ __ ] interrupt
each other and they interrupt you and
they don't let anybody talk they're not
listening they're just waiting for their
time to talk and you know it's it's so
strange they're not able to ever
consider other people's opinions they
think that everyone but them is wrong
and it's you know it's basically like
you know how it is when you see a
youtube video where people have no idea
how to fight you see them fight you know
that thing that is so crazy
I've this day I'm like I've been doing
martial arts my whole life I don't want
to fight anybody but I see people
fighting they have no idea how to find
him I imagine myself if I was in a
street fight with this guy I'm like this
is I would be like why are you doing
this man this is so crazy you don't know
what you're doing hey yeah hey you're
crazy you're gonna get killed you're
lucky I'm nice but that's the same way
with conversation there's a lot of
people out there having conversations
have no idea how to talk they don't
they're not even really listening to you
yeah they're just like why are you doing
that why are you arguing you're you're
in a conversation you don't even know
how to have one yeah you're not
listening you're just talking you're
just using someone like a like a wall
that you're throwing a [ __ ] tennis
ball off of it's bizarre yeah yeah yeah
well you got you had a kitchen
statement on this and I think it was
your last special like you have two
idiots in a room it's the more confident
one that they listen to yeah and it's
that that concept of you just just save
more words and you know how more in
opinions in you don't have to think just
be loud and make a lot of noise it's a
game they're trying to likes checkmate
you yeah instead of like having a
communication and conversation they're
trying to like socially dominate you and
this look I used to do it for sure yeah
um I mean I think it's a learned thing
you know you people do it to you and you
go man I got [ __ ] kicked my ass in
that conversation I'm gonna get better
at kicking people's ass and then you get
better at sort of bulldogging people or
talking over them or talking loud or
having these like these sentences that
maybe you could pull out of your ass
every now and then to shut people down
it sounds good and it becomes a sport
yeah instead of what it really should be
which is sharing ideas and communicating
with people like I mean if you're really
into the sport of just debating people
and shutting people down and insulting
people okay that good for you but people
don't like listening to that that much
yeah well people like listening to for
what I've not from my experience is
someone actually talking to someone
someone actually expressing their
thoughts and then the other person
considering their thoughts and either
agreeing or disagreeing but people are
so happy when you could do that without
real conflict yeah you know I've had
some people on that I just five years
ago I would have I would just said you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I would've screamed at
them what are you talking about you're
an idiot you can go [ __ ] yourself jump
off a bridge but instead of doing that
I'd be like okay why do you think that
and tell me tell me what about this and
then and here's what I think let me tell
you what I think you tell me what you
think yeah this to do that in a nun like
snarky wave yeah oh yeah you think that
yeah tell me more but but yeah like it's
how you get the best out of people
though that's how you understand who
they really are
yeah and it's so valuable so value but
for me it's just for me I know it's
valuable for people that are listening
but just for me as a human from my own
education it's been everything yeah
everything I've learned more from
talking to people
this podcast both from talking to
scholars and scientists and and really
intelligent people and morons yeah you
know I've learned a lot from talking to
[ __ ] it's just just the awkwardness in
the way they process thoughts and the
way they view the world and the way
they've chosen to communicate like you
learn from that just like you're saying
like well sparring with someone is like
doing has terrible habits yeah oh look
at this guy what the [ __ ] are you doing
that yeah but you learn you can learn
from people you know well I think that's
something that that really separates you
from a lot of people I mean like yeah
there's shows where people are very
opinionated and loud and you know people
like that and that kind of thing but
your ability to communicate and to bring
out conversation regardless of what the
subject matter is makes it very
intriguing and you can learn a lot
regardless of who the guest is like you
learned so much from these people
because of the way you are able to
communicate with them the way you're
able to bring out conversation and get
in depth with all of these subjects
well I'm genuinely curious about most
things and I'm genuinely curious about
the way I think I'm like why do I think
that way so if someone thinks different
than me I'm genuinely curious like why
do you think there's an instinct to go
now you're [ __ ] wrong I'm right but I
just go oh I know what that is that's
the trick don't do that that's that's
dumb don't think that way just try to
find out this is not a game it's not
contest yeah find out why this person
thinks this way and it's better for
everybody yeah but it's just a lost
talent like a lot of people do and I
didn't even know it was a thing you know
I started doing podcasts it just took me
a while like podcasts or like anything
else for me at least as I'm doing it I'm
trying to get better at it and I
realized I used to not be as good like I
can't I never listen to my podcast but
if I did listen to like the old ones
from the beginning I probably look
[ __ ] terrible Jesus Christ
you know Plus most of them I was high
out of my [ __ ] mind I don't know half
what I was talking about while I was
saying it I was ruining conversations
left and right but these conversations
for me are like it's like going to
school it's like every day I'm going so
about humans you know going to school
about whatever the subject they're
talking to me about but also going to
school about how you know the more
people you talk to especially like this
no cell phones we're wearing headphones
and there's one of the reasons I like
headphones is because your voice is in
my ear yeah you're not over there you're
right here man you're we're locked in
and this is exactly the same way that
other people are gonna hear it which is
a very unusual way to hear a
conversation yeah you don't think about
it that way but most the time when you
hear a conversation your voice is louder
because it's closer and they're over
there yeah yeah and you're talking to
each other and you know maybe you check
your phone or maybe you're distracted by
other noises but when you wearing
headphones you don't hear anything else
yeah so you locked in and when when else
would you and I and we're friends I've
known you for years when we'll be able
to sit down like this yeah for hours
just across from each other and each
other's eyes just talking yeah
yeah I never thought about that with the
headphones big yeah that's interesting
it keeps you from talking over each
other too much - because conversations
are improvisational right you know you
have a dance partner you don't step on
each other's toes but you do it
occasionally it's just so you get better
at it and it's for more than two people
it's mandatory like when you have three
or four people on a podcast you cannot
do it without headphones or it's just
talking over each other like I learned
that doing those fight companions oh
yeah because everyone's drunk and then
they have the headphones on it's sort of
at least calms some of the over talk you
know yeah that makes sense
yeah I saw its a journey man like
everything else
[Applause]